kennt ihr auch solche menschen die sich
für besonders schlau halten und dabei
eigentlich ziemlich inkompetenz sind sie
sind die besten autofahrer erledigen am
allermeisten auf der arbeit und sind bei
der fußball-wm eindeutig die besseren
bundestrainer
keine sorge solche leute gibt es nicht
nur in eurem umfeld
wenn man menschen fragt ob sie zu der
besseren hälfte aller autofahrer gehören
dann sagen 90 prozent davon von 800.000
schülern haben nur ein prozent das
gefühl dass ihre sozialen fähigkeiten
unterdurchschnittlich sind und auch 90
prozent aller professoren an
universitäten halten sich selber für
überdurchschnittlich gute lehrer
man muss kein mathematik professor sein
um zu sehen dass das irgendwo nicht
aufgehen kann
dieser effekt hat einen namen dann in
kuba effekt das phänomen dass menschen
mit geringeren kompetenzen häufig dazu
neigen sich selbst in ihrem können zu
überschätzen und so leid es mir tut du
bist du bist wahrscheinlich auch davon
betroffen und damit herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video auftakt oberson die
mit abstand besten kanal aller zeiten
beim dann in cougar effekt handelt es
sich um eine sogenannte kognitive
verzerrung das heißt das eigene können
wird weit überschätzt während das können
andere deutlich unterschätzt wird
oder ganz einfach gesagt sie dümmer
jemand ist desto selbstbewusster tritt
er auf diesem phänomen sind die beiden
sozialpsychologen da wird dann in und
justin krueger in ihrer studie 1999 auf
die schliche gekommen
sie wollten den zusammenhang zwischen
dem selbstbild und dem wirklichen
fähigkeiten testen
dafür haben sie mit studierenden einen
schriftlichen test gemacht der logik
humor und grammatik ab fragte nach dem
test sollten die probanden ihre arbeit
und ihr generelles logisches
denkvermögen selbst einschätzen
hier eine grafik der ergebnisse auf der
x-achse sind die wahren testergebnisse
auf der y-achse die selbsteinschätzung
der teilnehmer eingezeichnet wenn alle
studenten sich und ihre leistungen also
korrekt einschätzen würden dann sähe die
linie so aus beim vergleich mit der
selbsteinschätzung hat sich aber
herausgestellt dass die schlechtesten
teilnehmer ihre fähigkeiten deutlich
überschätzt wie die beiden forscher
kommentiert haben waren einige leute
also so ahnungslos dass sie nicht einmal
wussten dass sie ahnungslos waren denn
die betroffenen hat mich nur falsche
antworten gegeben sondern waren sich
dessen nicht einmal bewusst
ihnen fehlte laut studie meter kognition
das ist die fähigkeit die eigenen
kompetenzen zu erkennen
ein umgekehrter effekt zeigte sich auf
der anderen seite der fähigkeit skala
studenten die besonders gut abschnitten
schätzen sich selber schlechter ein als
sie wirklich waren
was wirklich schade ist denn sie
schätzen sich zwar insgesamt leicht
besser ein als sich die schlechtesten
studenten einschätzten waren aber um
einiges kompetenter als diese forscher
haben eine ziemlich interessante theorie
warum das so sein könnte kompetente
menschen gehen davon aus dass das wissen
dass sie sich angeeignet haben auch
allen anderen menschen zur verfügung
steht
und auch wenn das im heutigen zeitalter
mit dem internet und wikipedia zu einem
gewissen grad stimmen mag bedeutet das
ja noch lange nicht dass alle menschen
auch wirklich alles wissen
diese selbst unterschätzung nennt man
auch im posta syndrom im post bedeutet
hochstapler oder betrüger und so fühlen
sich leider viele menschen in ihrem
beruf obwohl sie jahrelang studiert und
schon viele projekte erfolgreich
abgeschlossen haben denken sie dass sie
eigentlich gar nicht so schlau sind wir
alle anderen glauben sie haben angst
dass irgendwann jemand fragen stellen
wird und auffliegt dass sie gar keine
ahnung haben was da überhaupt nicht der
fall ist
die eigenen kompetenzen werden maßlos
unterschätzt erfolge werden auf äußere
umstände wie glück und zufall geschoben
misserfolge hingegen werden den eigenen
fähigkeiten zugeschrieben
je nachdem welche studie man sich zu
diesem thema durchliest leiden 40 bis 70
prozent aller menschen in bestimmten
umständen oder zeiten unter diesem
effekt der grund für die
selbstüberschätzung am unteren ende der
skala ist allerdings ein ganz anderer
besonders häufig zeigt sich dieser
effekt bei halb anfängern in einer
erneuten studie hat dann mit seiner
kollegin carmen sanchez beobachtet dass
vor allem menschen mit ein bisschen
erfahrung zur selbstüberschätzung neigen
blutige anfänger sind beschreiben haben
respekt vor der aufgabe und wissen dass
sie keine ahnung haben
ich behaupte ja auch nicht dass ich
wüsste wie man ein flugzeug fliegt
obwohl ich noch nie in einem cockpit
gesessen habe aber es reichen ein paar
lernerfahrungen um die eigenen
kompetenzen deutlich zu überschätzen
nach den ersten flugstunden zum beispiel
befindet man sich schnell in einer
anfänger blase und hat das gefühl dass
man schon mehr oder weniger alles drauf
hat
dabei weiß man noch gar nicht was man
alles nicht weiß man hat erst einen ganz
kleinen teil der fähigkeit entdeckt erst
wenn man wirklich viel zeit hinein
steckt merkt man wie groß und komplex
die fähigkeit eigentlich ist und wie
viel erfahrung man braucht um sie zu
beherrschen
dieses muster konnten die forscher auch
im alltag nachweisen
dafür analysierten sie die daten der
national financial capability server
einer groß angelegten umfrage die über
jahre untersuchte
wie sich das finanzielle wissen von
personen entwickelt die auswertung hat
bestätigt gerade junge erwachsene
überschätzen sich erheblich darin wie
gut sie über finanzielle dinge bescheid
wissen
nun könnte man meinen dass ganz
klassisches feedback hier einiges helfen
könnte man sagt den anfängern einfach
hey schau mal du hast hier hier und hier
fehler gemacht die zeigen dass du das
ganze thema eigentlich nicht verstanden
hast aber komischerweise sind die
meisten anfänger danach immer noch sehr
optimistisch was ihre eigenen
fähigkeiten angeht was wirklich hilft
ist die art und weise wie man über
intelligenz nachdenkt andere studien
haben nämlich gezeigt dass menschen die
intelligenz als fixe eigenschaft
wahrnehmen allgemeinen überschätzen wie
gut sie in bestimmten aufgaben sind sie
erinnern sich eher an die teile eine
aufgabe die sie gut gemeistert haben
das könnte ein unbewusster
schutzmechanismus sein denn wenn man
wirklich davon überzeugt ist dass
intelligenz angeboren ist und man daran
nichts ändern kann dann tut es ziemlich
weh zugeben zu müssen dass man an einer
aufgabe gescheitert ist menschen die
intelligenz jedoch als eine fähigkeit
wahrnehmen auf die man einfluss hat und
die man verbessern kann können ihre
leistung akkurater einschätzen
sie erinnern sich sowohl an die dinge
die sie gut gemeistert haben als auch an
die dinge mit denen sie schwierigkeiten
haben und die guten nachrichten sind man
kann intelligenz verbessern
durch regelmäßiges training und lernen
kann man seine kognitiven leistungen
steigern
ihr müsst also keine angst davor haben
einmal durch einen test durchzufallen
viel größer wäre der schaden wenn man
intern analysiert dass man recht gut in
etwas ist und sich dabei selber belügt
kleine randnotiz an dieser stelle kinder
die gelobt werden indem ihnen gesagt
wird dass sie intelligent sind haben
mehr angst davor risiken einzugehen und
sich neuen aufgaben zu stellen
als kinder die gesagt bekommen dass sie
hart gearbeitet haben letztere verstehen
lernen als einen prozess auf dem man
einfluss hat und haben deswegen mehr
selbstbewusstsein
es könnte sich also lohnen auch als
erwachsener zu hinterfragen wie man sich
selber wahrnimmt bin ich von natur aus
ein intelligenter typ oder bin ich
jemand der an problemen arbeitet bis ich
sie lösen
okay was lernen wir jetzt aus dem dann
in kruger effekt erstens ist es gut sich
überhaupt der tatsache bewusst zu sein
dass man sich als anfänger gerne mal
überschätzt
das hilft dabei peinliche situationen zu
vermeiden man ist eben kein experte
nur weil man seine ersten drei töpfe
getöpfert hat
oder die ersten paar paper über den
klimawandel gelesen hat wahre expertise
kommt durch jahrelange harte arbeit
falls ihr doch diese jahrelange
erfahrung in einem gebiet habt und ein
wirklicher experte seite zb einer der
weltweit top wissenschaftler auf einem
gebiet dann lasst euch nicht von
anfängern dazwischenreden die eigentlich
gar keine ahnung haben und sich selber
maßlos überschätzen
und zweitens kann man den dann im kruger
effekt auch nutzen
experten sprechen von selbstwert
dienlichen verzerrungen das heißt
dadurch dass wir unsere leistung besser
einschätzen pushen wir automatisch unser
selbstwertgefühl und fördern damit unser
wohlbefinden und unsere neugier
wenn ich zum beispiel nach den ersten
fotos mit meiner neuen kamera direkt das
gefühl habe dass sich preisverdächtige
fotos schießen dann hilft mir dass dabei
weiter an meinen fähigkeiten zu arbeiten
mir macht das fotografieren mehr spaß
wenn ich das gefühl habe dass sich auch
gut darin bin auch wenn ich nach vielen
tausenden fotos und echter erfahrungen
dann sehen kann dass meine anfänge
eigentlich nicht so der kracher waren
also seid neugierig probiert dinge aus
und lernt neue fähigkeiten dieses video
wurde unterstützt von merck merck ist
ein wissenschafts und technologie
unternehmen und möchte uns alle im
rahmen der neugier initiative
neugieriger machen um innovation und
fortschritt zu fördern
denn nicht nur intelligenz auch neugier
kann man trainieren aus welchen
elementen neugier besteht und wie man
sie aktiv trainiert das erfahrt ihr bei
den qs element hier gibt es verschiedene
taktiken in dem ihr zum beispiel neue
themengebiete erkundet oder fotos
bewusst neu interpretiert diese taktiken
helfen dabei seine neugier im alltag zu
steigern
einen link zu den taktiken habe ich
unten in die video beschreibung gepackt
vielen dank an merkt für die
unterstützung bei diesem video
danke an euch fürs zuschauen und wie
immer bleibt neugierig und drückt den
daumen nach oben denn das war ein
überdurchschnittlich gutes gefühl
[Musik]